What are you willing to do...
...and what are you willing to give up to be the best you can be?
You only have so much energy and the clock is ticking on all of us.
If you're gonna compete against me, you better be willing to give up your life...
...because I'm giving up mine.
Brady.
End zone touchdown!
Daddy!
Jay-Z taught us 30 is the new 20...
...and Tom Brady is showing us 40 is the new 30.
There's a warrior spirit about me.
I'm always in competition with myself.
You know, I have to say I don't think I've ever met anyone that loves to do something...
...as much as he loves football.
You don't want to make sacrifices for your sport...
...but when you have a family, you do!
When I see myself out there,...
...I feel like, "Man, I still do this and I do it better than I've ever been..."
"...so why should I stop?"